I had an experience working
there was a friend of mine who took the
other path
and went to work for some of these
criminal groups
I was operational and I was
we saw a bunch of people in a gas
station parked
back then the main you know Moses
operandi that they had was that they
would impersonate or dress up as federal
police
and that's how they would move around
the city
we saw these Suburbans in a in a in a
gas station
and some of the guys were carrying on
our AK-47s you know and that's that's
not a standard issue firearm
so
you know we saw that and I got off on
foot and walked by
to try and get a
you know better sense of what was going
on I took everything off uh
wearing jeans and a t-shirt
and I got a whistle from one of the guys
uh that was there and my name was called
it was one of the guys that I grew up
with
redhead kid looked like El Canelo you
know
uh there's redheads in Mexico by the way
I think it's probably some of the Irish
that uh that betrayed the American side
during the last mexico-american war that
stayed down there had a bunch of kids so
it's probably from there love is
stronger than anything else it says
redhead kitten
when I say kid I mean he was my age now
to my eyes he's always going to be
younger now
he whistled told my name
say hey Guess The Geek out I'm like what
are you doing here it's like ah She
Gotta just you know going home and
she'll go and get a taxi it's like oh
okay he's walking as he walks over it's
like he has a plate carrier with AK
round uh magazines on his chest uh 8K
without a stock on it
it's carrying in his hand
he comes over and he hugs me I could
feel the uh the magazines on my chest
mind you I have a gun on me you know
tucked
and uh Nextel is buzzing in my back
pocket
as people are trying to you know figure
out what's going on
um he asked me small talk [ __ ] like hey
he's like what are you doing like what
do you work at I'm like I'm just looking
for a job you know you used to work at a
video store
so he's like I haven't seen you in a
while
uh I was so and so of your family good
and how's your family good
it's like yeah they're like this is an
interesting job you have he's like yeah
it's pretty good they pay us well
you get a you know you get a car you
know there's money
and nobody [ __ ] with you you get
respect I was like that's awesome you
know and if you want it can get you in
you know if you if you want that's like
Ah that's I'm too much of a coward for
that I told conversation like any other
yeah between two friends he hugs me
before I go
I accept something doing I can't
remember what
and he says Hey in my ear I know what
you do for a living it's not a safe
place for you to be in
and I walk off
a few moments later the Army showed up
and you
could feel the amount of rounds going
off from two blocks away
we came back with our guys
then it was it was over
so he didn't survive that
I looked through the bodies and the cars
that were left you know there was
bodies all over the place people left
there
it was a mess
they spent like an hour looking for him
the only way I could recognize him was
his hair
um I stayed with his body
all night there's a
there's a bridge
in Tijuana that goes over the river in a
place called La Mesa
and that's where the forensic offices
were
his body was taken there and I stayed
with his body until it was released
I told his family about it
because I knew them
in that aspect of you know us versus
them or they're the enemy and she like
that
you know my mom
told me those words now nobody's against
you they're just for themselves so don't
make the mistake of dehumanizing anybody
and those roles could have been easily
reversed
I could have been shot in the face there
that aspect the conflict brings worth
let's say bad guys good guys you know uh
Heroes villains you know I
there's an innocence to that that uh it
goes away